welcome back to the games foot stage
here at e3 2016 tomorrow night I'd now
joined by Dominic Butler the lead game
designer on Tom Clancy's Ghost Recon
wildlands thank you so much for joining
us thank you for having me it's a big
name Ghost Recon wildlands actly exactly
but it's it's a game we're very proud of
yep
we'd have a shorter name like internally
just wildlife just Weiland's yeah I
don't even think that I Canon would work
no I don't have it yeah it would be
unpronounceable I think but yeah wild
lands is the easy way to go so what
you're showing off at e3 this year so
III this year in fact we'll start with
III last year we brought the game we
unveiled it for the first time and kind
of brought the dream of what Ghost Recon
could be what didn't you know what that
evolution could be and then this year
we're super happy because we're able to
put it into fans hands so even like last
year we had the behind-closed-doors demo
and it was kind of VIP invite only and
then then now we've got it
there with it's on the booth it's open
to the public we've got at the ub lounge
we've got hundreds and hundreds of
people lined up and it's the feedback
has been incredible I know because with
something like this you work on it for
so long the game's been in development
for almost four years now
and you kind of keep it for yourself and
then you you show the world you're not
sure first reception was great and then
obviously those people have questions
okay it looks great but what's it gonna
be like to play and then they put their
hands on it and it's great it's the one
restriction that we have I guess is it
being a three we've got a limited amount
of time with you and that's the bit that
is the only like I wish you could play
it as much as we do this is the build
that we've taken from the floor this is
the bill that we play every day and we
put it bluntly we didn't have time to
build like a sort of bespoke III demo we
took a slice of the game and brought it
with us to e3 and knowing the fun that
we have with it and the opportunities we
see every day seeing players get to play
that that's the the kind of the big
thrill and there's something we're gonna
bring back to the guys in the studio
obviously obviously goes recons a
historic franchise and it's been kind of
in and out of you know the lime
like so a lot of people may want to know
like what is the makeup of the team that
is working on and we talked earlier and
and you have a lot of like classic Ghost
Recon devs on the team so for four
people little fans of the series like
yeah absolutely absolutely well what we
have is the game is being led out of
Ubisoft Paris and I mean Ghost Recon it
holds a special place in Ubisoft heart
it's one of those like old franchises
like you said it it kind of comes and it
goes and then it comes back again and
every time it does we try to bring
something new you know we try to see
like what could we do to make it
different and but still retain that
tactical military shooter still retain
you know the DNA what makes it Ghost
Recon and really because the team makeup
more than anything else we've got a lot
of guys on the team these are the ex
Future Soldier guys these the guys have
been working on it since you know for 10
plus years so they know the brand better
than anyone you know we've got other
support teams but they're coming in to
help those guys who really know what
those recon is and for long quite a long
time with these several games in fact
we've been wanting to make it bigger and
bring those tactical options to the
open-world but we've been limited right
but mainly by tech limitations more than
anything else and now leveraging the
power of these current generation
consoles LED leveraging the power of the
current generation pcs were able to
bring those tactics with the coop with
being able to play with your friends
that whole sensation that freedom of
choice to the open-world where it just
feels like a natural fit right it's it's
no longer this linear corridor say ok
let's do a mission where we're gonna
attack this place at night in the rain
I'm gonna drop in behind enemy lines
we're gonna wait for the guards to be
kind of doing different patrols we're
going to avoid the spotlights and go in
and extract a thing or the big explosive
ending to the chapter and you know these
kind of things that we used to set up
typically when we were building games
like that now we put that into the
players hands and we say ok you've got
to get this guy it's up to you and we
you know we give you the options we give
you the tools and like I was saying in
before it's it can seem a little bit
limiting sometimes when it's a kind of
coordinated demo but when we've got 20
minutes for a person it's hard to get to
show you all those options but
items and tools and the drone we see
here in the drone has its own bespoke
progression system the players got their
own progression system offering the tons
are different it's not even new ways to
play it's more like you can express
yourself through the gameplay and just
play the way that you want right and
that's the thing I think that's that's
really important for it I mean from a
game design level where do you even
start like you you say okay this mission
I want you to kill this guy extract this
guy where do you go from there where do
we go from there well it actually starts
earlier than that where we we look at
building a world first right and we know
we have an experience that we want for
the player in terms of the kind of an
overall creative direction and that
comes from our brand guys the guys that
have been building it for a long time so
they know what the sensation that needs
to be maintained right in terms of that
tactical approach and then we see okay
what are the tools one of the things we
can give to the player but a also
against what kind of backdrop because
this is Bolivia it's a near-future it's
a kind of what-if situation with this
drug cartel that's moved in seize
control of the entire place and turned
it into a narco-state you know what
would that look like what would it feel
like what would the reaction of the
world being in our case that's the ghost
that's an easy option for us but it's we
build this world with this kind of
intertwined systemic ecosystems it's not
just a geographical thing it's the
traffic it's the civilians it's the
rebel forces it's the Santa Blanca how
they've taken over these places what was
a village what was a mining Center and
then using that not just for a kind of
visual theme but also for gameplay
opportunities right because if you're
attacking like a mining quarry or a base
that's on a hill or something that's
added in the SOL planes those things are
widely different challenges not just in
terms of like the story says I've got to
extract this guy but even if you just
kept it as extract this guy putting it
in those different situations wildly
changes the gameplay so it kind of
starts before all of that and then we
try as much as possible to leave it open
and to avoid having kind of let's say a
sense of playing it wrong we know we
don't want to have it that is a wrong
way to play this game it's if you want
to say let's roleplay this and go full
tactical sure we're gonna give you all
the tools to do we're gonna give you all
the options you need you can recon with
your friends you're gonna share that
information you move in silently the
world is going to react accordingly but
if for example after a time you say you
know what we've been super quiet for a
while I want to go big on this short you
get those options take off the
suppressors get the c4 get the mines get
renée's put them on the side of a
helicopter fly it in and blow it up
right on top of the camera it's a ton of
fun so the classic Ghost Recon games and
even somewhat like stuff like Rainbow
Six Vegas they were like almost like
trial and error you get these tight like
almost choreographed very precision but
yeah yeah whereas this seems like it's
more designed about going in and then
reacting to situations so there is a
sense of the reaction but the reaction
is there it's not let's not say it's not
a punishment and that's there that's the
really key part is it's not a punishment
for playing it wrong it's more
consequence where you can see oh you
know what we did make a good approach to
this camp we did you know we did
everything well and the way we wanted to
play but at the last minute I mean in
the video we're showing you here we were
going after el pozolero and the key
thing was he fled yeah but he spotted
one of the ghosts and I'll be completely
transparent with you we did kind of get
spotted so we could show you the chase
but the chase isn't a scripted thing
right the chase is based on his reaction
all of these bosses all of these major
characters have their own personality
have their own backstory have their own
narrative in their drive and it informs
their characteristics the way that they
play so in some cases you'll go after
somebody and maybe you get close to them
and they surrender immediately and
that's it they're just they're scared
they're they're not violent people they
were accountants or they were involved
in other parts of the business they
don't want to fight and others are gonna
hunker down and they're gonna get behind
cover they're gonna start returning fire
others are gonna flee this guy runs and
we wanted to show you that kind of cool
systemic chase and how things can
daisy-chain and and the sort of
consequence the chain reaction of events
that can happen right and it's it's a
but it's really for the players right so
then you'll see in the top left corner
it gets tracked el pozolero right that's
there from the beginning of the video
it's like you just get him get him to
the safe point how you do that it's
entirely up to you the bosses reactions
remind me a little bit of the Nemesis
system in
model the way that each kind of oak Moss
reacts in very different ways right okay
question from the chat is what engine is
it's running in so this is running our
own proprietary engine which are all our
own internal tech it's a version of
anvilnext system that we have built some
of our games on quite successfully and
we're very happy with it but it's all in
house stuff okay in terms of story the
Ghost Recon games like I'm trying to
remember back the previous like Advanced
Warfighter stories like I think I can't
for life of me remember them I remember
a series of missions where as with this
it seems like you're making an effort to
try and tell the story you've got
Bolivia you've set up this narco steak I
think yeah is there an increased
emphasis on trend telling like a a
narrative story with an arc and kind of
you have these ghosts behind enemy lines
they seem kind of isolated from the rest
of the world and absolutely I mean we do
you want to feel that threat right you
want to feel a little bit like you are
that SpecOps you are dropped in behind
enemy lines you do have a CIA handler
who's gonna be giving you some
information along the way gonna be able
to coordinate a little bit with the
outside world but you are as you're
there by yourself
you know and you are having to do it
like those guys have to do it when
they're doing missions like this they
kind of have to rely on their expertise
the fact that they can fly and they can
drive and they can pick up any weapon
that's the thing that these guys really
do and they have to be able to adapt to
that situation they have to kind of seek
out opportunities identify threats and
act on that right and that makes for
fantastic gameplay from our point of
view because it's a bunch of
opportunities this big toy box and
without saying you know no don't do this
or you have to do this or you want to
approach this camp you have to do you
know take out these two guards then
disable the alarm then do this then do
just it the way you wish right and
there's no wrong way to put we saw in
the easy time a player will play co-op
yeah how is that gonna work as a drop-in
dropout is there a lobby is that much
making so we're not talking to
specifically about the the way we
connect with other players for sure the
important thing I'll just kick it off
with is that the game is playable in
solo and up to four player co-op from
the beginning to the end and we make no
differentiation between I started in and
solo so now I can't join co-op or vice
versa
you're always just playing Ghost Recon
wildlands you're always playing your
narrative your progression and then as
you jump in and out of other people's
games we have a quite a interesting way
I'm not gonna go into now of basically
merging our narratives so that I don't
autocomplete stuff in your game you
don't autocomplete in mine but we can
still share the experience we stat can
still grow and in if for whatever reason
I have to leave you guys keep playing
you're not missing out you're not kicked
out to a lobby you know you don't have
to stop and in terms of those options
for the player we also have the solo and
it's important because not everybody
wants to play with other people some
people prefer the solo experience that's
fine you're not missing out on any
content at all you will be supported by
three AI teammates and those guys it's
necessary right like the spec ups guys
that we talk to you we got you know
still serving guys and retired guys in
different military authorities and every
time they reinforce the fact that
there's no lone wolves there's no way to
do this by yourself so you can need that
support that's reflected in the kind of
elevated difficulty in the fact that
it's a really dangerous world you need
extra fire support or if you go down to
be able to revive you or vehicle support
all of those things that you would have
with friends you're not gonna miss out
with with the AI teammates can you
control the AI teammates in any way you
give them some direction it's
interesting you mentioned earlier about
the kind of more precision based you
know like door entry stuff right let's
plan this and let's mark charges here
and you wait for my mark and then you go
we don't want to have that kind of
micromanagement it's totally fine it's a
ton of fun I love playing those games
but for our world where we kind of
embrace the chaos a little bit more and
a little bit more can happen we wanted
to leave it open and make it a little
bit less directed so you give them basic
orders army attack retreat whole but you
use that same communication system when
you're playing with friends so it's not
like I'm learning to control the AI it's
it's the way I talk exactly the ghosts
of themselves are they defined
characters like are they speaking and
having their own personalities are they
more for like customers no no no no so
in terms of customization real quick
from the beginning you get to make the
ghost your own right so in terms of race
and gender and
mint and load-out and everything that
you're taking into the field with you
you customized all of that and then you
can upgrade and adapt that as you
discover more tools and options and like
what we're showing at e3 you've got it's
like quite a basic sort of starting load
out that isn't overwhelm you with the
ton of options right but that's gonna
grow that's gonna you're gonna adapt and
you're gonna build a kind of toolset
that you like in terms of the ghosts
themselves they all have very distinct
personalities they're all completely
voiced they're talking to each other
they're commenting on stuff that's
happening in the world they're
commenting on things that you've
affected by your gameplay in the world
because it's a large systemic world so
depending on what you do the world kind
of reacts to that and they then can
comment on those reactions right so as
the Santa Blanca starts to put
punishment on the locals because you're
fighting and you're trying to fight back
against these guys you can have the
ghost commenting you buy this
you've got regular communication with
the CIA and that's kind of stuff so it
is something that again we don't have
time to show now but it's absolutely
there in force thank you so much for
joining us for having when are we able
to play a Tom Collins Ghost Recon
wildlands will be released on March 7th
2017 awesome thank you so much thank you
guys and of course for more ìiî coverage
don't go anywhere stay tuned to
games.com